[Music]
in our series pay attention we explore
ways to sharpen our focus and recapture
our attention from distracting
technology we recently spoke with
Twitter co-founder EV Williams who
Forbes called the LeBron James of online
publishing he stepped down as Twitter
CEO in 2010 and later started the
blogging platform medium Williams who
remains on Twitter's board regularly
steps away from technology through
meditation yoga and walks in the woods
are you intentional about how you spend
your attention with respect to
technology yes they're very much so
everything from what notifications are
on so what apps are on your home screen
for instance if I'm on vacation I'll
move my email off my home screen and I
won't check my email as much when I'm on
vacation so little things like that that
or even having a watch I know a lot of
people's like I don't need a watch I
just look at my phone so you look at
your phone then you're in a whole
another world they look at my watch I
know what time it is it's a discrete
thing you've done it it hasn't pulled
you off your intention exactly what I
like to do in the morning is I don't
check email I don't check news or or
anything so mornings are pretty quiet
and I mean not quite with the kids but
quiet in terms of technology and
information and once I leave the house
then I'll often turn on a podcast or an
audiobook and sometimes I'll keep it off
just like okay what's going on the mind
just kind of like look or maybe I'm
focusing on project but that start of
the day
I carve out do you think there's a value
in being bored mmm yes I do think
there's a value in being bored I was
tremendously bored as a kid I think it
forces you to use your imagination and
when my kids are bored which is rare I
always say that's great that's so
exciting you're bored what do you what
are you gonna do what are you gonna
think about what is their response when
you say it's great to be bored
roll roll their eyes and complain of
course just like any kid and sure what
what I did what as a kid he's one of the
dangers of this moment we're in where
there's always something to keep us from
being
word yeah I think I think there's a
danger not having border and not not
having silence and our inner minds and I
think that's why meditation to having a
formal way to actually just quiet the
mind that's so important is because it's
constantly inundated do you think
Twitter is responsible or as part of
that inundation period or feeling I
think people can get swept up and
Twitter just like in or any social media
and for sure and people need to be
conscious of how they use it
is there any way in which medium is a
kind of antidote to Twitter in that
we've become so focused on the now and
the twitch that we need really to be
pulled into something deeper well the
way I think about it is like an
information diet and that you can live
on on social media alone often it's it's
that hamster wheel of what's happening
right now what we try to do with medium
is provide a space for things that
aren't necessarily of the moment whose
responsibility is it to solve this
challenge that we all feel and I which
is the shredding of attention I think
first of all the responsibility is on on
ourselves for ourselves and for our
children we're in charge of what we put
in our minds and and to blame anyone
else for that I think would be not fair
and not wise what about the technology
companies though who are playing on our
attention well I think that there's some
responsibility there certainly and I
think there's a new awareness in in the
companies that I'm familiar with that
it's not all good necessarily it can be
too much
and anyone building technology I would
expect if they're being responsible
their goal is to actually serve people
and if that's not the goal then I think
that they should rethink you have kids
you had kids and what are the rules for
devices with them we have rules they're
six in eight they don't have any social
media accounts they have iPads we let
them use them on the weekend for a
limited amount of time and an hour or so
so we're figuring out as we go and we're
trying to set good examples but we don't
always do that my little one the other
day
I was I was on my phone and he was
waiting for me is that why your adults
always on their phones
yep yep thank you for that reminder Jack
Dorsey who was a co-founder of Twitter
with Williams spoke out recently about
the companies saying it had a toxic
content problem our interview with
Williams took place before dorsey's
remarks but in a new statement Williams
wrote that media companies should have
responsibilities but ultimately the
responsibility lies with all of us as
individuals and parents to be both
critical thinkers and open to ideas that
don't conform to a narrow view of the
world it was reassuring to hear that
even he struggles with how much social
media and screen time their kids should
have right because it's something that
all parents are experiencing and
managing attention is a practice it is a
thing you have to be constantly plan
yeah I like to watch ideas yeah just
look at your watch and something you
have to take responsibility for